you
Omega
at 1800 hours our cyber virus will
infect all American cyborgs letting them
complete later the control of a mega
force the detonator before you is
connected to a nuclear bomb within a
city of Los Angeles once the virus
strikes detonated and your mission will
be complete oh yeah I guess that means
you guys I've never trusted in Android
till today
it's been an honor serving with you
likewise credible I want to shoot my
shutdown procedure before the virus
kills me
you're hurting me
that virus is pretty fast
Robert I do not do that credible spy
directive it would be wise for you to
sleep at this distance it's not people
here approximately 30 seconds after
definition I'll kill you 20
Oh
you
[ __ ] robots
hey we usually don't talk it into these
videos we hope you guys like it we just
want to say thanks everybody helping is
possible also if you want to see more
check out the behind the scenes we made
we're huge fans of Parker i3 being able
to make a Blood Dragon video is an
awesome experience if you have no idea
what you just watched in each new
context check out the trailer Blood
Dragon you know probably all make sense
then